hello let's play a game you know you're
like the 10th guy to try this right
maybe
[Music]
everything that we did in five we wanted
to really challenge in six
big felt like coming home I love being
back
it was always the plan to keep them
alive we you know we I think we still
have
residual
sadness sadness do we you know it's like
and I think we you know we felt that
that was really important for that movie
but for this one we wanted to make it we
talked about this as a secret feel good
movie a lot and that was a part of it
[Music]
you're gonna be all right
I survive I always do the bones of this
story were very much the same and I
think um you know I think that one of
the things that
that we're really proud of is that there
are echoes of Sydney in in this movie
and I don't think there's a way for
there to not be Echoes of her in any
movie going forward I think that um you
know she's she's the first thing we fell
in love with in the franchise and I I
hope that that's um that that love and
care for her characters is present in
this as well
dude we brought back Billy Loomis as a
hallucination Anything is Possible
antipsychotics aren't working as well as
they used to are they
it's what we were saying about this
being a secret feel good movie which on
our read of the first movie is very
similar where you know the original Trio
and of course Randy they all survived
and that's really special to us and I
think it's why it's so rewatchable it's
why we all love it and
Guy and Jamie when they're writing the
script for this they were able to really
lean into the strengths of all of those
actors because we've worked with them on
the last one and it was so special to
watch their friendships off camera be
mirrored on camera you know and they've
gone through something in real life and
now they've been going through the
something you know in the movie with
Coast space and it it's just those
scenes to us are the most special in the
whole movie because there's something so
palpable and authentic about it they
they're they're really they're just
lovely surprise
and I think there's something really
it's one of the benefits of this movie
happening so quickly after after five
that we find the characters so shortly
after the events of of the last movie
and they're in that really weird messy
stage of dealing with the events of five
you don't have to reintroduce some new
conflict right into those into those
characters lives like we we've we're
there with them it's really it's really
immediate that proximity created um some
immediacy in those just what's happening
emotionally that we thought was really
really interesting to explore
the way I see it someone's out to make a
sequel you know cash in on all the movie
murder hoopla so it's our job to observe
the rules of the sequel number one the
body count is always bigger number two
death scenes are always much more
elaborate more blood more Gore Carnage
candy I think you know we we look to
that as sort of a a uh a Guiding Light
for how to follow up a movie that you're
proud of and the people like uh and I
think you know one of the things we took
from screen two besides like the setting
of college and that stuff that was
really cool to us was those set pieces
in Spring 2 are so iconic and they're
some of our favorite in the entire
franchise and so to have the opportunity
on this one to do something similar and
really like blow those out that was a
big part of it
Parker Posey
yeah that's a good answer I mean look I
know I'm gonna step in it but
I'm getting another beer you want one
yeah sure I'll be right back
just Force ghost Star Wars Force ghost
all of them
we're not really sure what the path
would be for seven but we know that I
think you know built into the the DNA of
what this franchise is they always have
to take a risk and reinvent themselves I
think it's why five and six feel so
different we were challenging everything
that we did in five we wanted to really
challenge in six and so I imagine Guy
and Jamie who are probably gonna hold
off somewhere riding writing right now
um have have a big weird plan for scream
seven we have no idea what it is you
ready for this
thank you
foreign